the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu hi my name is provoking Erin
are supposed to be 1 over 4 but it
remains that i am the only one so my
project was about global illumination
and it's about rendering 3d scenes so
first let me tell you about the duration
model this is something you can achieve
with ray tracing as you can see the
image above is rendered by shooting
array from your eyes and then taking the
local lighting properties of the
materials and then see whether there's a
light coming to that point or not and
then figure out the color so in this
model there's a lot of thing unnatural
about this because as you can see the
light is an area light but then the
shadow is like a very solid shadow as if
it's lit by a point light in something
like that and you can see that of the
ceiling is not late at all um this means
that this model of lighting doesn't take
into account the light that bounces
between the walls and lighting parts
that should have been lit lit in the
real in the real life seen as you can
see so global illumination basically
tries to fix that and the effects you
can achieve with global illumination
algorithms or basically soft shadows
color bleeding you can see that there's
a very pale shade of blue here and
caustics which means that lights from
here goes through the glasses and then
focus on here so at first when we
started when I started project I want to
globally illuminate a very simple scene
which is the
parnell box it's just basically this box
bits and you replace these two spheres
with two white boxes and then you can
observe color bleeding something like
that um and I want to do in real time
with caustics however the things I
accomplishes are well I global you
illuminate the quinella box as i
promised in real time now there's it's
too slow with caustic didn't implement
photon mapping but and sadly there's
still a lot of rooms for optimization so
kind of disappointed in myself a little
bit but yeah that's so the algorithm I
use um for Ansari global illumination is
called instant radiosity it's by some
German guy called like Sandra Keller
it's good for scene with diffuse objects
well which means that scenes that
doesn't have objects that reflects light
or LED light transmitted through diffuse
objects can be just this table and
something like that basically it means
that when lights writes it it just
bounces all randomly as such it can do
caustics although it is very simple to
implement once you have the core so let
me describe the algorithm you start with
the light source and then you emit auto
fuel light particles and let them
bounces around the scene and then you
will have some more light source and
then you raytrace using those light
source of the sea basically so this is
the illustration of the algorithm first
you have the light which goes off from
this square light and then you
illuminate the scene with it and then
you bounce some lights off and then
illuminate the scene and then you
combine the results basically so in my
implementation I just have at the
beginning I have one SP you scatter all
the light particles
the number of light particles I scatter
is about 128 and as they bounce around
it ends up to be about 250 light sources
in total and then i use i render the
scene by splitting the scene into some
horizontal slabs and then just keep the
the slabs to each SPU to render in this
way since the scene is very small can
just preload them to every SPU and they
all can work independently so there's
minimal communication going around and
since I didn't implement any other smart
data structure to take care of the
geometry i just used boot for ray
tracing my scenes have only eight
objects it doing st use are doing
rendering or a ray tracing Oh ray
tracing basically but I mean doesn't an
array move from one slab to another
depending on a reflection or something
um no basically if you trace a light
there of the ESP you have all the
ascription of the scene so we can trace
the Ray throughout the scene but it's
responsible for only the pixels in the
slammer um the complexity is kind of bad
because all the times you the time is
you have your email size the number of
pixels times the number of light
particles which is about 200 and then
since I use brute force ray shooting we
have two times but times by the size of
objects but at first I thought I have
only eight objects anyway so it's not
going to be a big performance track but
then I came to a realization that this
algorithm initially was conceived for
using with programmable graphics
hardware which can do really dumb tasks
like taking a point light source and
illuminated scene with shadows very fast
so it turns out that this algorithm is
not really suited for the cell basically
I wish I could have done better on this
this 500 x 12 x 512 scene took 20
seconds to render on the cell but the
original paper they render something
bigger a little bigger than this in 24
seconds with GPU basically so it's kind
of disappointing hello um yes but not
very clearly at 20 24 seconds on what
kind of machine um 24 seconds on a 75
makers something machine with the GPU
just using vs cpu and the GPU and that
10 times that by six basically however
the speed-up is proportional to the
number of processor used I basically
graft around time with the number of
processors this is in lot scale so as
you can see it so that's the best you
can do about parallelism there basically
yes sir runtime is normalized to just to
keep you using the SVU so what are you
in for y axis the y axis is time in
seconds i 0 3.7 yes expression for one
into you yes three points of them sick
sick and / 1 SP you and ask you increase
um the times go down you just divide
that matter they're all using the TP you
as well um no the pp you do anything so
I can you say 20 seconds on your
previous line oh this is different image
slice yes okay okay okay okay if we
start in that picture this is 128 so
it's about 16 times faster um I couldn't
wait for lighter yeah so here are some
images are rendered there are eight
objects in here and it took like 20
point five seconds with 6 SB use another
image that I rendered is a miniature of
a cornell box it to 20 points two
seconds and six SP you ah yes I don't
know that as well maybe it's above maybe
it's about the distribution of the
particle light source probably I think
when it goes to the wall or to the floor
it's get severely attenuated that it
cannot really lit the ceiling basically
also there's a comparison between my
rendering and the wheel Gordon box
basically yes there there's still a lot
of box around they
basically the ceiling is not lit and
it's kind of strange that I see some
great tinges here instead of great green
as in this one so probably I have to fix
that as well but as you can see we have
a sheep soft shadows and then some
colored meeting how do you determine the
location of the light sources um how do
you idea tuned to our you input to the
lights work yes space and they can be
arbitrary positions and within the box
or yes basically um you this one is just
a square object which is written in the
scene description file and I can locate
them where basically and the my patio
goes down from here
so there is something that can be
further optimized basically if I had
decided to use accelerated data
structure the complexity of that image
size x objects x number of light sources
this term will be reused to lock and
probably you see about 3x be done
basically there are some the the most
popular wind is probably be right what
is it call it for example the KD tree
for example and actually I learned in
class that basically you can achieve
about 2 or 3 X beat up by rearranging
the data so that you can trace for rays
or 16 ray at a time instead of doing one
at a time in the approach I'm taking and
if you do that there's it's faster
there's also in this in the program I
have a lot of objects and each of them
has a transform associated to them so
that it can locate them very well
wherever I want and the object can be
anything but there's another approach
which says I just take anything to be a
collection of triangles and if you have
triangles the description is just three
points on in space and you don't need
transform to do location is something
like that and basically checking whether
ray hits aren't hits a triangle or not
will be faster so thank you very much
do you know the work that was done here
by Julie Dorsey elimination I have she
basically used the trick of pre
computing doing the great racing flirt
with some fixed number of source
locations and then just rendering in
real time by taking our linear
superposition of these great great race
images so so long as you could
approximate your light source by a
linear combination of some fixed
repertoire of light sources you didn't
think about taking that shortcut
presumably I didn't think about it they
mail you something like that as I have
two units my food let's see um so
so basically there's this output GGA
which I'm going to remove because I'm
going to generate it the scene i'm going
to render going to be a cornell box with
a Q and a sphere in it yes I can just
move the object in the licensor sure
let's change it to a point light source
then
I see so right now the current light
source is this um square I'm going to
comment it out and change it to the
point light source here and that's too
quick but
basically there's a point light source
located around here so the scene is lit
one point light so as to expected the
shadows fire so just divining the scene
equally seems it would get good load
balancing if you had like roughly equal
complexity across different sections yes
if you have a really complex I object or
if you have like reflections that go
much deeper some places than others Oh
couldn't an equal division lead to too
bad load balancing I mean did you think
about other divisions I suppose but
basically other approaches that I think
of which basically probably can divide
the scene in a really fine grain manner
oh you just do like that's driving yes
other reason why you do professors man
asked how much is to communicate how
often do the SP you communicate with one
another right and the PPU and how often
do I do that basically at well before
the ESP you start running the PV you
send at the same description and then it
senses the tasks that say i want you to
render this pixel to this pixel and
that's it and then the SPU just streams
the pixels to the main memory yes yes
you